[Music]
[Applause]
all right let's get this [ __ ] started
[Music]
right
right
[Applause]
[ __ ]
[Music]
joy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
wow
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
we don't get no justice now
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh
is
[Applause]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
again
[Music]
[Music]
wake
empire
people used to live here
[Music]
[Applause]
no justice
[Applause]
no justice for the ground
bring it down
[Applause]
make some noise for yourself
[Applause]
[Applause]
streets
[Applause]
street
everywhere we go everywhere we go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
make some noise
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ]
oh
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
we say
[Applause]
[Applause]
he's
[Music]
gotcha
[Applause]
oh
what do we
everybody
in the back
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Applause]
is
before
black people
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
one two three four five six seven eight
nine eleven
[Music]
so they can stand there and get some
[Applause]
overtime
[Applause]
oh
oh
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
what
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Applause]
we are the people too
[Applause]
is
we are the people too
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
people
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
we want freedom
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
i'm not telling you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
is
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
complex
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
help me
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
peace
[Applause]
shut it down
[Applause]
[Applause]
okay
[Applause]
me
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so yeah yeah we got the whole space
right here because
old space and stopping traffic until
every black man and black women's name
has been sent
and they get the justice that this
country has not
given us that we [ __ ] deserve
[Applause]
for days months
years black people
have not gotten the justice that they
deserve but after today we will
after today we will today
it's just a step next is a conviction in
a sentence
[Music]
we want life without
[Music]
[Applause]
we parole that our humanity be
recognized
our lives matter and it starts with
black
people and black children and black
trans women and black women
[Applause]
are sitting in traffic over here they
gathered up on the sides they're like
why the [ __ ] are these people still out
here
why are we still here there was a
conviction yada yada
y'all have heard it from me already but
i'm gonna say it again
for all new york city they're here
one conviction is not enough
[Applause]
there was one conviction was not enough
but one conviction was really not enough
there were four
officers there there were four there
were three other people who stood by him
why did somebody healed on a man's neck
for nine minutes and 29 seconds
it took us almost a year to get justice
for that
and so all the horns honking on that
shot showing support you can wait too
[Applause]
i treat everybody
out here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
i heard i touched on the jeffersons
i heard ultimate ultrasound i heard that
i saw a club
deal that was shot in the car in
minnesota
so we're gonna hold your faith into this
country
treats black people the way you would
want everybody to be [ __ ] treated
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
they're all dead they're all victims
of this system and it doesn't matter how
many settlements how much millions of
dollars their family has none of that
matters
because they're dead but this system is
not limited
only to those that died there are over
two million people incarcerated in this
country
the majority of them black and brown the
majority of them for non-violent
drug offenses
[Music]
there are another 2 million people out
on parole who get monitored
by these same these same people who
police us and put us in cages
so when we're saying names it's not only
these names
it's corona zarya it's the lieutenant
getting pepper sprayed in his car
it's the nine-year-old little girl
getting pepper sprayed on the side of
the street
it's all these people because
consistently
at every angle black people are targeted
and we are assaulted and we are
criminalized
constantly and the fact that i'm seeing
black and brown officers standing here
looking like officer friendly
y'all know it's true too y'all know
those officers standing next to you
[ __ ] the car don't protect you if you
spoke your mind right now
if you came up and said how happy you
are that derek shoving got convicted
you know damn well the white shirt
behind you gonna look at you like you
crazy
i'm talking to you says you know what
i'm talking about too
so i need y'all to remember and i'm
gonna keep saying it and i'm gonna keep
saying it again and again
this fight does not stop today with a
conviction of derek's shoulder
that is the bare minimum this fight
does not stop until there is not a need
for us to come out in these streets
and march as same names and watch people
die
every day in 4k hd
that's when this fight ends and that's
where all these people in traffic can
stop honking
[Applause]
[Music]
when a black woman is speaking you be
quiet and you shut your mouth
period black women have been
on the forefront in the front lines
raising our
[ __ ] children putting their lives on
the line
their humanity must be [ __ ]
recognized and we are here to say
protect
black women so when she speaks you shut
the [ __ ] up
thank you
[Applause]
all right thank you so much for letting
me speak today
and talking about the struggles of so
many black people in america
and how these struggles is connected and
how they connected
not just police terror but just the the
reality
of being black in america and being
black under capitalism
and i want to give an example of that
there was a 15 year old by the name of
makia bryant
who was shot four times in the chest
by columbus tv that's just one example
of how black life is degraded every day
in this system
that's just one example of how every
time
another black person tries to even live
their bare minimum life
they are being told that it is not worth
living
that's why we haven't been up there to
stop the war on black america
exactly because what we've seen every
day is a war unleashed
on black america we've seen that
continue to happen
when they forced us over on slave ships
we see it continue to happen
when we fought against jim crow
apartheid and we see it continue to
happen today
and what we see in common here is that
it is a system of racist oppression that
benefits from it
and that system itself is
must be abolished
say it again sister
i say the system that oppresses us the
systemic structure which exists
and benefits financially from the
oppression
of black and brown people must be
abolished
because we want to abolish the courts
and the police but we want to take it a
step further we want to abolish
capitalism
i want to abolish racism
we want to abolish all the systems of
oppression that have held our people
and and kept us in handcuffs and these
people honking today
are on their way to go wherever they
have to go but just realize
for nine minutes this man suffered for
nine minutes he cried out at one
point and said mama and the first thing
i thought when i watched that video
and i was in tears was i heard eric
garner say the same thing
i can't breathe i can't breathe
[Applause]
and he wasn't given the basic courtesy
to live his life
when freddie gray's back cracked in half
in the back of that police car
these are stories of terror and violence
and they will not end they will not end
until we get up and we put on our foot
on the neck of the system that oppresses
us
it must be all precious screaming make
it not breathe
and that's what we've seen this trial
start to begin brothers and sisters
this trial is our class seeing its power
getting a taste of the reality that
could be on us
getting the taste of justice for beyond
justice liberation
so brothers and sisters i'm just gonna
end with this
let us continue to be out here and build
this movement
let us continue to be out here inspire
others who may not feel like they're
powerful
enough to have a voice but you know what
no better today
because because of you this happened
this is the people's burdens
this is the people's justice
one step in the ultimate direction in
that direction is liberation
and that direction is dismantling the
system itself
and when we have that brothers and
sisters we have truly won
down with capitalism downward races [ __ ]
the racist police who murder us every
[Applause]
day
[Applause]
they matter where
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
they matter
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
they matter
is
[Applause]
and threaten those killers
the whole damn system is guilty as hell
[Applause]
[Music]
shut it down
don't get it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
who keeps us safe
that we want to join
[Music]
[Music]
thank it
[Applause]
[Applause]
are we going to union square all right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
wake up wake up this is your fight too
we don't wake up
wake up wake up wake up wake up
where's the energy
wake up wake up
[Music]
wake up wake up
wake up wake
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so oh
[Applause]
[Music]
so much better everywhere we go
everywhere we go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
these racist cops have got to go
and we don't get no justice now
they called it before
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
what do we do
seven eight nine ten eleven
four two three four five six seven eight
nine eleven
one two three four five six seven eight
nine
[Music]
um
[Music]
come on y'all make some food
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we
we
[Music]
we
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
say his name say his name
say his name say her name
say her name say her name
say her name black lives matter
black lives matter matter
black lives matter matter
black lives matter
[Applause]
these racist cops have got to go
if we don't get no justice now
we're gonna burn it all down
if we don't get no justice now
[Music]
these
[Applause]
who protects us
[Applause]
right
no trust me
[Music]
police
i am
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
you can't stop
[Music]
you can't stop the revolution
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten eleven
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten eleven
[Applause]
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten eleven
[Applause]
[Music]
no justice help me no justice
help me [ __ ] these great glass bubbles
[Music]
[Applause]
fire fire petrified
fire
oh
[Applause]
people want to know who
god
[Music]
[Applause]
adam's life
i said no justin [ __ ] these racist hats
for me
no justice no justice
no justice [ __ ] these races
[Music]
[Applause]
all these nice folks who like to put
their cameras out the windows and take
videos of us
and cheer us all they can
ain't nothing more defending the police
though from what i've found
we gonna make it nice and
[Applause]
justice
is
[Applause]
for summer but i think it matters
so when i say white silence yeah say
is violence right silence
hate silence white silence
make some noise
[Applause]
[Music]
no justice no justice
[ __ ] these racist ass police
no chesters i said no
no way [ __ ] these racists as police
let's look at the person left into the
person to the right of you
feel where their heart and their pain is
with all the amount of black bodies that
have been
tied that have been lynched that have
been slain
that have been burned that have been
raped
when will it end
[Applause]
how do you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
black lives matter black women
black children black
[Applause]
[Applause]
hate
[Music]
and white supremacy and white supremacy
and white supremacy and black
supremacists are
foolish on supremacy apology
abolished white supremacy of allah
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
let's run that
tomorrow
[Applause]
[Applause]
abolition liberation not tomorrow now
abolition liberation not tomorrow
now abolition liberation
abolitionism
abolition liberation
black lives black children
black women black families
black love black sex workers
black wrongfully incarcerated black
formerly incarcerated
black currently incarcerated black
foster care youth
black men black trans man
black queer black non-binary
and white supremacy
and white supremacy
abolish capitalism
abolish capitalism
and white supremacy
polish capitalism
make some noise for yourself
[Applause]
all right repeat after me
mama mama
[Music]
ain't no justice in this town ain't no
justice in this house
don't you cry mama mama don't you cry
before you leave
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
they put us down
what the system's
is
[Applause]
is
[Music]
they locked the stuff they put us down
[Music]
this is not justice i'ma say this now
i'm gonna say this forever
this is step one and we're gonna keep
fighting until it's done for sure
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
black
[Music]
we want
[Music]
is
doesn't get
if
[Music]
what do we want what do we want it no
no justice no peace no justice
no peace no justice
no justice
[Music]
don't just sit down stand up and take a
stand
is
make some noise for yourselves please
[Applause]
one we are the people too
say it louder three we want justice for
black people
we want
[Applause]
[Music]
black people
as we come into this park we want
everybody here to know that this thing
don't stop
so y'all
[Music]
you can't stop the revolution
one two three four five six seven eight
[Applause]
[Applause]
make some noise
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
one two three four five six seven
[Applause]
[Music]
100
[Music]
[Music]
we're gonna
[Music]
[Applause]
if we don't get no justice now
we're gonna burn it all down
make some noise for ourselves
now as we stand here we are taking a
knee and holding [ __ ]
space so please take a knee
and sit down and get educated thanks get
comfortable yeah get comfortable
as you look around i want you to
turn to the person next to you have a
conversation
introduce yourself allies you already
know the guild
we need to accomplish this and
co-conspirators we need people to
protect black people and put them out of
harm's way
so please have a conversation educate
one another
because the fight continues
this is not a moment this is a
[ __ ] movement
this is not a trend this is our fight
as we sit here we think about the other
names that still need
justice we demand that the other names
whether it's black trans women black
women black men
black children black foster care youth
black sex workers
black gang bangers black foxly
incarcerated
currently incarcerated those who are
public assistants
those who are in housing projects we are
out here for them
never forget that give yours give
yourselves a round of applause for being
out here
[Applause]
this fight is intergenerational
this fight
[Music]
we stand on the toes of giants
we stand as a force so we may be young
but we are organized we are [ __ ]
strategized
you put in the [ __ ] word
this fight you need to understand and
know
what are you sacrificing your blood
sweat and tears
must be in this fight so as you go home
you educate your uncle your aunt
those who are misogynists those who are
homophobic
those who are transphobics those who are
fat phobics
who are disrespectful to black women
this fight will never end
until we abolish capitalism narcissism
this fight will not end until we abolish
white [ __ ] supremacy
because nobody is free until black
people are free
until black women are free until black
students women are free
until black children are free
this fight is not a choice
activism chose us we became activated
because of injustice to have to see
those who are killed to gun violence
those who are killed to police brutality
those who are killed during human sex
trafficking
know what you are sacrificing for and
putting your life on the line for while
you are out here
this fight will continue until we get
justice
for the people justice for all justice
for black people
excuse me because as we march as we knew
as we protest
we deserve our humanity and our rights
just like this just like this country
says they are willing
to be the land of the free for all this
country has not been free for black
people
all power to the people all power to the
people
all power to the people our power to the
people
all power to the people
to the people all power to the people
all power
please repeat after me it is our duty to
fight for our freedom
it is our duty to fight for our freedom
it is our duty to win
it is our duty to win we must love and
protect
each other we must love and protect each
other
we have nothing to lose
one more time it is our duty to fight
for our freedom
it is our duty
[Applause]
god bless each and every one of you and
continue to go in peace thank you
let my brother say from strategy for
black lives please give him a round of
applause
all right so this is not the third time
i spoke tonight so i'm gonna really keep
it short and sweet
um i really appreciate
all y'all pharrell i appreciate
it's not enough to post your little
black square on instagram your little
hashtag
to tell a black person i'm so sorry this
is happening to you
it's not enough to do that truthfully
the time has passed for all that and
i will speak that i don't normally do
this but i'ma speak directly to
our white allies that are here
it is not enough y'all
are not doing enough this is not a trend
this is not something that you pick up
and put down when it's convenient
this is not something that you falsify
care for you don't do that
and truthfully a lot of you are not in
their heads and yes
right but what are y'all doing to do
more
what have y'all done to contribute
have y'all been out here every day were
you out here when it was snowing
were y'all out campaigning for whoever
exactly sleep out here are you out here
supporting our businesses
are you out here providing us jobs are
you out here
doing everything in your power to
advocate for us not because
not because we're black not because of
anything else other than the fact that
this is the right thing to do
it is the right thing to do to stand up
it's the necessary thing to do to stand
up
and from today going forward i'ma say it
again it's not enough to just convict
derek showdown
it is not enough and it's not going to
be enough to convict the other three
officers
and it's not going to be enough to
convict him it's not going to be enough
to greet any of them
the only time when you will hear me tell
you that it is enough
that you have done enough is when i no
longer worry that i will die
on my way home
you